okay another game slime what am i I'm
one out of three it could be worse could
be better
I'm just trying to play like some decent
games okay we'll help qgd at queens got
declined exchange variation Queen c2
I'll play the smooth yeah this is kind
of newer opening theory I played this
like a good handful of times and
previous tournaments and online games
one main idea is 96 to b4 and like we'll
usually play a three Hey I wear shoes
welcome back thanks for subbing for nine
months
okay so 96 Bishop g4 should be logical
as well well that's measurable I think
could I look back at your history
thanks for the bits will chess
I won't take all the credit though for
all the reading people of Cain's what to
do here Bishop d7 busy bee sevens kind
of a tricky move it looks nonsensical
but the ideas actually took clear the g4
Square it's not I'm threatening this
this and this so it has to be careful
here
there's no f3 f3 is a typical plan but
Haines III might have three back okay so
I won't repeat just trying to gain time
albino Alpine I'll walk thanks for
subbing
okay let's repeat again I mean I can
play Bishop each Bishop h5 doesn't look
right though I'll just move back
White's happy with a draw that's the
problem so okay I'm gonna go for
something more I'll usually when I play
96 the plans to do this I think I can
still get away with that question is do
I take on before first but taken b5 i
sat sattvic p thanks for subbing for
three months
yes I'm stopping White's minority attack
I'm also fixing the pawn on b4 so now
it's kind of a kind of a long term
weakness with the structure white
usually wants to play e4 95 also
interesting like g5 the idea is just to
fight for the square muscle unleashing
the rook it's a tense position f4 my
force probably good move because I want
to play 94 but I can't or can't I maybe
probably not yeah let's be sad oh I'm
gonna be extra sad just lost a knight
for nothing please don't see it I'll
plunge saw it that's so bad we just lost
a knight Renato I got made it to all I
was so bad oh wow I was just complete
downward spiral that wasn't even the
spiral I was just like falling down a
pit I was so bad I just
gave away the whole game in two moves
ouch I don't know whether to be tilted
or just more awake I feel like that was
more of just a wake-up call it should
just see more squares on the board I
just I just missed I missed two squares
h7 and f7 just polite spots I mean here
okay I really just missed the pin but
then I just missed them amazing one I
was terrible if this goes on youtube
people kindling can rip me apart in the
YouTube comments and be disappointed
with me yeah